das ist der politische aufreger dieses
tages ein neuer asyl pakt für migranten
denen unsere neue innenministerin da
plant in europa nancy faeser was steckt
dahinter es geht um innerhalb der eu
eine koalition der aufnahmebereiten
mitgliedstaaten also nicht alle sollen
aufnehmen sondern die die bereit sind
und die anderen sollen zahlen im
klartext heißt das doch deutschland soll
mehr flüchtlinge aufnehmen als bisher
oder ralf schuler unser bild parlament
scharf ihrem studio schönen morgen ja
das bedeutet ist und frau feser die neue
bundesinnenministerium startet damit
einen versuch mit dem eigentlich sowohl
angela merkel als auch ihr vorgänger
horst seehofer schon gescheitert sind
denn es gibt in europa keine koalition
der willigen es gibt auch in westeuropa
weil sich ja alle immer auf osteuropa zu
konzentrieren keine bereitschaft
nennenswerte große kontingente
aufzunehmen wir haben das zuletzt
gesehen bei den migranten aus moriya aus
griechenland da hat seehofer versucht
eine größere verteiler gemeinschaft
zustande zu bekommen am ende haben 13
migranten aufnahme in luxemburg gefunden
und das war es dann auch also das ist
von vornherein nicht sehr aussichtsreich
weil sie geplant danach haben wir immer
wieder gehört dass mori angesprochenen
es aber auch zuletzt der weißrussischen
grenze gesehen wird es immer wieder
davon gesprochen dass europa eine
stärkere zusammenarbeit brauchen dass
man sich mehr zusammenfinden muss wie
könnt ihr diese zusammenarbeit wenn du
sagst dieser vorstoß der ist eigentlich
schon zum scheitern verurteilt denn
aussehen damit da wirklich mal endlich
weiß ein bisschen in die gänge kommen er
hat es geht vor allem um ein anderes
projekt nämlich die stärkung der
grenzsicherung nach außen frontex ist da
immer wieder genannt die grenzsicherung
agentur aus brüssel und die arbeitet
seit jahr und tag nicht effektiv auch zu
mehr auf dem mittelmeer ist es sehr
schwierig das zu bewerkstelligen zu
lande an der weißrussischen grenze wäre
sicherlich einfacher aber da kommt man
nicht zustanden nicht zu vorwärts da
gibt es zu wenig geld da gibt es zu
wenig leute und es gibt länder die sich
dagegen sperren fremde grenzsicherung
truppen auf ihrem territorium zuzulassen
das ist also alles sehr kompliziert die
verteilung ist aber genauso umstritten
und da gibt es nach wie vor keine formel
es ist ehrenwert das zu versuchen aber
es
schafft mehr probleme als es wirklich
lösen kann jetzt schon auf jeden fall
riesen diskussionen über diesen neuen
vorstoß von nancy faeser unserer neuen
bundesinnenministerium ministerin und
jetzt wollen wir darüber sprechen mit
dem csu europapolitiker markus ferber
der uns zugeschaltet ist migrations
packt ein neuer ein neuer asylbewerber
schönen guten tag bei bild live was
halten sie von diesem vorstoß von frau
faeser schönen guten morgen dieser
vorstoß ist schon im beginn zum
scheitern verurteilt wenn sie sich
anschauen wie in frankreich wir haben
jetzt französische ratspräsidentschaft
wie in frankreich das thema diskutiert
wird in der vorwahlkampf phase da wird
es auch aus frankreich keine initiativen
geben wie sie sich das vorstellt und zum
zweiten geht es ja darum eine gemeinsame
europäische lösung zu finden und nicht
ein sammelsurium von einzelaktivitäten
man kann nicht auf der einen seite
umgang kritisieren weil sie einen zaun
bauen polen dafür loben dass sie einen
zaun gebaut haben
migranten von lukaschenko und
zurückschicken und das als erfolg
verkaufen auf der anderen seite er für
die schlepperbanden neue wege eröffnen
also das ist alles sehr unausgegoren und
in europa weder mehrheitsfähig noch
findet sie da viele freunde wie sollte
man die asylfrage denn dann auf
europäischer ebene angehen ja natürlich
schon die herausforderung ist es uns mal
auf gemeinsame standards an der
außengrenze zu verständigen und auch da
ist deutschland er kein gutes beispiel
weil jeder der an der außengrenze
erfasst wird wird ja in deutschland noch
mal geprüft also da müssen wir uns in
deutschland auch mal angehören in europa
zu werden und gemeinsam ihr verfahren zu
akzeptieren das zweite ist was überhaupt
nicht funktioniert in keinem
mitgliedstaat dieser europäische union
ist die rückführung für die sie
offensichtlich keinen asylgrund haben
das ist eigentlich das hauptproblem er
das von vielen staaten
formuliert wird er was nutzt mir das
wenn wir regeln haben gebe am ende doch
dazu führen wer es irgendwie nach europa
schafft werfer am ende da bleiben daran
hapert es bis heute das hat er in allen
mitgliedsstaaten nur damals war wirklich
europäisch antwort finden mit
bilateralen ab - mit der türkei haben
damit nordafrika ist es bisher nicht
gelungen mit zusammenarbeit in der
außengrenzen kontrolle was wir in
nordafrika schon als europäische union
das sind die antwort europa geben muss
bei europäischer antwort durchzuckt mir
jemand schon und ich denke klappt
sowieso nicht sie haben das problem ja
auch nicht lösen können auch die cdu
kanzlerin nicht und wenn man jetzt immer
weiter sagt nie klappt sowieso nicht
wahrscheinlich auch bei diesem neuen
asyl parkt also von nancy faeser
entspricht das wahrscheinlich der wahl
also ist die wahrheit die eu kann das
gar nicht kann gemeinsame
flüchtlingspolitik nicht kann dieses
problem nicht lösen gemeinsam die eu
könnte es schon wenn endlich auch mal
vorschläge unterbreitet werden die
unterstützt mehrheitsfähig sind also
wohl schon claude juncker also davon
allein haben vorschläge auf den tisch
gelegt in der rat gar nicht anrührt dann
wenn man die vorschläge nicht vernünftig
sein hier sollte vielmehr sondiert
werden was ist machbar wie kann
solidarität in unterschiedlicher form
zum ausdruck kommen und noch mal es kann
ja nicht sein dass am ende die
schlepperbanden darüber befinden wer
nach europa kommen darf und wer nicht
das sollte man schon wir selber tun
vielen herzlichen dank für diese
einschätzungen gehören also raus es ist
nicht einfach eine lösung dafür zu
finden einen gemeinsamen europäischen
weg zu finden bleibt eine ganz große
herausforderung danke für ihre
informationen und einschätzungen